it was 1997 I was 14 years old and she
was my best friend's girlfriend was it a
dick move yes but to be fair I kissed
her first it was like the previous
summer I'm hanging out with Mike and Jen
it might give me your best friends we
handle a lot she's got a well on line
Jen and Mike aren't dating yet we're all
just hanging out a Jen's place watching
MTV Mike falls asleep on the couch Jen
and I are getting closer you know we
start holding hands when kissing and
more kissing and then me putting my hand
under her shirt I you know I think
something's gonna happen but it never
does I just didn't articulate that we
should be dating just couldn't say it
and then she ended up dating Mike
because Mike is older than me and they
were the same age and if you're the same
age should be dating right what's the
deal with that Mike was a Seinfeld thing
so they start dating over my eighth
grade year I get to my emo phase I hit
puberty that's cool sort of that summer
my brother Patrick and Mike get caught
shoplifting at the Walmart and his
parents are he gets grounded for two
months he can't leave the house he came
to telephone so Jenna and I are left
alone like the trio is broken up and I
talked to Jen on the phone a lot and
then one day is like hey can I come over
I'm just bored so we hang out of my
place I don't have cable it's not that
fun so we're just getting close we're
holding hands
we're stroking thighs it's then that I
know oh man I can have sex for the first
time in my life it's possible I can't
let this opera
passing by so I go and get a condom for
my dad sock drawer the lifestyles condom
I guess it's weird and it's the same
prophylactics that my dad was using to
have sex with my mother
Jen and I just walked 45 minutes back to
her place like five miles I've got my
best outfit on a beige van my citrus
worn shorts my lime green shirt I've got
five black MTV baseball cap hello
supercool car beeps at us I can only
assume that it was because I look like
an idiot we get to her house nobody's
there we go to her mom's bedroom and we
start watching HBO making out one thing
leads to another I was like you know
what I think it's time I'm gonna pull
out this condom do you want to uh and
she says yeah okay she rips open the
condom with her teeth that was cool in
my mind that was that was like whoa
that's cool but that that's that's
erotic couldn't figure out how to put on
the condom anyway put it on we get to
lovemaking
I call it lovemaking because yes I was
in love and I was doing this for love I
am a gentleman and I've got older male
friends who have told me the things that
you should do to treat a lady to a nice
time but none of us achieve climax I
didn't ask her I can only imagine that
she didn't and I know that I didn't like
we're done I go to pee I also look at
myself in the mirror like Who am I now
what if I become my a good person my man
now was expecting to have a mustache I
don't know Mike
anymore and they keep dating I'm like
well I guess she doesn't love me it was
heartbreaking to see them together still
you know I think she told him I didn't
tell him you know I wanted to tell the
world I just went my sad little way and
went to high school who knows if I if I
if I told her that I loved her and that
we should be dating we could be married
though or not don't have sex if you're
not able to communicate those feelings
and you're relying on sex to do that for
you
you